there's a bunch of people that will say
well I've a family so you know it's a
great idea for you to just go out there
and go crazy I have people to support
you need to listen stop saying that
stop saying any of those things every
single person who has ever done anything
worthwhile or exceptional or difficult
or extraordinary anyone whether it's
great artists or authors or
mathematicians everyone encounters
difficulties there is no easy road it
does not exist it is impossible
everyone has issues when you come up
with excuses for why other people are
successful in your not that is dangerous
when you give yourself an escape yeah
well that's easy for you to say
everybody has a hard road I wanted to
jump out of windows several times during
my young life I wanted to jump in front
of a train just end it because too much
pressure we all go through hard times we
all go through depression we all do go
through doubt and then moments in your
life where it's really difficult and
you're trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] your path is gonna be it's hard
that is what makes you a person and
those difficult moments are what build
your character show me a great man who's
the son of a great man these kids that
are born billionaires you're never going
to be a self-made person you have a back
up trust through your trust I'm
fascinated by martial arts I'm
fascinated by comedy I'm fascinated by
many many different things I don't
understand when people say they're bored
because if I had the time to live a
hundred lives I'd be speaking different
languages I'd be living in different
countries I would I would try out a
number of different careers because I
think there's a lot of unbelievably
fascinating puzzling complex things that
you could study in this world and I
think that is one of the things that
motivated me to explore difficult tasks
because through difficult tasks you
learn an incredible amount about
yourself and you through the fire of
competition you get to understand
motivation you get to understand the
resistance that you have inside your
mind to doing the hard work
you get to understand the rewards of
discipline like you don't truly
appreciate relaxation unless you've
worked hard and that is the yin and the
yang of life one of the worst decisions
a man can make is to be comfortable you
just watch - amazing clips from Joe
Rogan take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]